voyons maintenant le travail d'une
organisation humanitaire sur le terrain
dans l'un des douze pays où la situation
est la plus grave
nous partons en république démocratique
du congo dans le sud du kivu à la
frontière du rwanda une région ravagée
par dix années de guerre on continue à y
mourir de faim leur reportage de nos
envoyés spéciaux j'arrive ses rangs
change mines en quoi les hauts plateaux
du kivu à 2000 mètres d'altitude
une terre pourtant fertile avant les
combats fratricides entre rwandais et
congolais
nous accompagnons une équipe d'action
contre la faim en tournée de dépistage
de la malnutrition
car avec la paix les habitants regagnent
leur village
or la guerre a détruit la majorité des
champs de manioc et pour les cultiver à
nouveau dans les cases
nous ne croisons que des veuves et des
orphelins à l'orb et le deuxième à
mobilité
le cri d'une jeune fille elle vient
déposer à nos pieds
son petit frère
cent dix à huit ans il pèse à peine 14
kg l'enfant ne tient pas debout
l'équipe ne pourra même pas plier ses
jambes pour le mesurer un peu plus d'un
mètre à 8 ans bao nous la grande soeur
raconte elle se bat pour le maintenir en
vie
leurs parents sont morts quand il est né
et elle n'a plus que lui pour famille
mais elle n'a rien à lui donner à manger
voilà leur repas quotidiens ça c'est
l'effet des maniaques ça et ça c'est la
même chose on voyait la main même panier
c'est bien que des lots nsn
l'équipe propose d'en porter le petit
garçon mais il s'accroche beaucoup de sa
soeur elle trouve que c'est lourd pour
elle elle est fatiguée elle n'a plus des
forces la maison indienne assistance ce
qu'elle insiste marc où nous emmènera
l'enfant sur son dos jusqu'au village de
lemera action contre la faim ya ouvert
un centre de nutrition thérapeutique
il abrite aujourd'hui 80 cas de
malnutrition sévère comme sandy famine
et maladie ferait actuellement 1200
morts par jour dans tout le congo 110
lui devrait être sauvé avec du lait
enrichi le premier bol est dure à avaler
mais pour la première fois de la journée
un sourire sur le visage de mahounou
advanced heures en fait est une vraie
petite mère courage d'ailleurs à la une
poignée assez étonnante
ça fait huit ans qu'il se bat pour
sauver son petit frère elle a réussi il
va suffire de trois semaines de cure
donné thérapeutique pour que ce petit
garçon puisse rentrer chez lui on voit
qu'il faut pas grand chose en afrique
pour sauver des milliers d'enfants